I consider myself a fairly Mimi guy like
I'm fairly internety I'm not very
plugged into pop culture but internetti
I have a large collection of memes yeah
and one of my producers I will not say
which one embarrass this producer said
are you aware of this meme of Joshua and
I said I'm not they said it's it's this
funny meme it's from a porn scene yeah
it became it took on a life of its own
yeah so it's you
it's you in a bathtub and someone comes
in and says hey you're at the beach and
you need a lifeguard or something you
say I'm not in a beach I'm in a bathroom
or something yeah yeah so
um to
so there there was this Meme and it's
been shared probably I think it's been
shared over 100 million times it became
really popular on me uh on Vine and then
it became really popular on Tick Tock
but there's this scene where this goes
to the ridiculous of the writing it
happens in pornography but
um I'm in a bathtub and then a lifeguard
runs in yeah and she's like get out
there's a shark in the water
and I was like
what are you talking about lady like
this is a beach it's not a you know this
is the this is not a beach yeah yeah
that's so that's what I say it's like
this is not a beach it's a bathtub and
but with it with like like straight face
you know you know it's funny it is is it
it's a very funny but in that it's
maybe maybe a lot of porn is like this
but it that strikes me as it's so
self-aware about what it is there's no
there's no real pretense it's just like
haha we're here right yeah I mean she
like she ran in with like the little
like lifeguard thing and she's wearing
like she's dressed in like like Baywatch
you know she's got the red bathing suit
on you know and she comes in I'm just
sitting in the bathtub and that's and
that's the meme it's like this isn't a
beach it's a bathtub like is the meme so
if this went viral during the years of
Vine
were you out of the industry at this
point or were you still in it Vine was
like 2012-ish yeah so I got out at in
2012. this is right around the time yeah
so it went it went viral then and then
it went and then people started like
remaking it on YouTube and then it got
popular on Tick Tock as well
um and then I found out about Tick Tock
and I was like and I oh so through
finding out like how like popular Tick
Tock was being I take I took a peek at
Tick Tock and I'm like oh this is not
for me you know this is bad this is bad
news yeah so you think regular social
media is bad tick tock is just cracked
because there's no home screen right you
just always in some video with music and
then but then I then I talked with
someone and it was like well there's um
there's your your for you page and then
there's a page where it's just the
people you follow yeah I was like
anyway
and they're like well you know they're
showing me data it's like how many you
know this is the most downloaded app you
know in this age demographic and so on
and I started thinking like well okay
you know my objective is to reach people
with the gospel so how could how could I
leverage this for that I'm like let's
let's think about this and then I start
doing some research and then someone
sent me like hey have you seen this meme
or like something about the meme and I
was like I have no idea you know because
it became popular like after I was out
of the industry so I have no idea about
it and I I did some research and I was
like man like 100 million views like 100
million times this thing has been shared
it's like as far as like popularity of
memes it was like top 20 it was like you
know it was when one at one point it was
like one of the most popular means that
existed and
um I was like this is this is ridiculous
and then I made a tick tock around it
and it was like but it was like uh who I
who I used to be and who I am today and
it was just and it was just like a back
and forth of like it was that picture
and then like me getting baptized and
then like that a picture of me in the
industry and then me getting married and
a picture of me in the industry
um and then you know me like you know in
my family yeah and then you know it
reached you know so so I've been sharing
like not just with the moon but just
like sharing my testimony
and uh so just I I shared something
along that lines on Instagram uh about a
month ago and it reached seven million
people
but the organization that we put
together so it's one thing to reach a
lot of people so we've got an ecosystem
where there's you know using AI uh there
there's there's key words that if you
type
you'll get a message and that message
routes you to an opportunity to you know
like biblical literacy or like talk to a
person or if you're struggling with
pornography there's there's a website
that we've created that there's a 10
steps of how to be free from it and so
it took that it's great to reach
millions of people but we took that and
and create a systemized way of
connecting people all those people to
The Next Step whether it be like freedom
from pornography or hearing the gospel
or being connected to a church or
whatever